hi hi i just want you to know
that i watched the documentary and
there was so much stuff i related to
yeah
and i'm really excited that
i might get the chance to talk to
somebody
um that might understand
certain things that i have experienced
and felt and gone through
and this is all about you but i just
can't tell you what a safe space you're
in
what an amazing talent and
incredible force you are i just want to
talk
you know girl to girl woman to woman i
think in
our weird trajectory of life you
grow up so fast and you're in these like
adult jobs and yet you're not
an adult but you're like hanging out
with other kids sometimes and working
with them but your peers aren't kids and
yes and what your responsibilities are
and what you have access to and
definitely
like you're the one paying the rent so
it's like really weird i always rebelled
against authority because like deep down
inside i was like
i'm paying around around here my parents
like they did the best that they could
um there's no manual on how to raise a
child star
and when the child star retorts back
after the parent says you know you're
grounded for
sneaking out at three in the morning
whatever um
when you know i retorted with well
i pay the bills what are you gonna do
like what are you gonna do to keep me
grounded
and so it was challenging and it was
also really
really interesting like i i started
working on set
at eight years old on barney and friends
yeah and so um and so i
was around adults at eight years old and
i actually like always got along better
with
adults than kids like for some reason i
just
that was just always me and so when i
got around a lot of adults like i
felt more comfortable but you know the
adults leave work and they go and have a
drink
the kids what do we you know so there's
this weird um
thing to think about especially then
when you become a teenager in hollywood
and your adult peers are
you know like i said going to a bar
after work or whatever
and you're 17 thinking
well what do i get to do to to play you
know and
and it it left this weird you also like
i always i have this mentality of like
if you're gonna work me like an adult i
get to party like one
but the reality was adults weren't
partying like i was
so no but it's true i remember
i always wanted to be the person
who like had a martini at the dinner
party and like
was getting a cocktail but i'm the girl
who probably just drinks too many
martinis at the dinner park
um it's like okay let's just start
earlier because
when you have to put the good the bad
and the ugly out there
even at a ripe young age i don't
understand
why the press feels like they have the
right to ask you anything
and why we also feel like the people
pleasers who have to answer all their
questions
yes yes yes totally totally i i've
battled with that a lot even in the um
first few interviews after you know or
getting ready for the
documentary to come out um i was
answering questions that i realized i
was like i don't have to answer these
and so we do i like to say that i'm an
open book
with boundaries because i feel like
i do wear my heart on my sleeve but i
also
have learned how to protect myself from
um people just like
intruding a little bit too much on
the personal stuff well i got really
angry
when that guy on the red carpet i think
it's that gentleman chris
uh whatever his name is i forget his
last name chris harrison
um and you know he's a funny guy and
he's out there working and
this is no offense to him it could have
been anybody
it's not personal for him but when he
says you're 16 what do you know about
heartbreak which isn't the worst
question that's been asked but totally
because the narrative the documentary
has just revealed
that you had been through so much by 16.
i wanted to rip his face off why does he
have the right
to say that to you you know i think that
the reason why we get angry
when we watch that clip back is because
we're looking at a 16 year old girl
answering the question it's really
easy for us to look at a teenager
and feel empathy for her i definitely
have i think that's so interesting
the way you're speaking about it it's
very high road
it feels very zen and calm i still have
the
angry little rebel in me that no matter
how open i am
i think when entitled quippy
questions come out i still hearken back
to times in my life where i'm like
i wish i had had the ability to say
i gosh you know i've been so open but
i'm gonna have to say like
not gonna answer that absolutely and at
some point
you have to say all right i'm putting my
foot down and i and i
i gotta say no i can't answer these
questions anymore and i think
it's never too late to set a boundary
with the world
and i i learned that um
and i and i've continued to set
boundaries where
i know it seems like i've talked a lot
about
my life but i didn't talk about
everything and that's where my boundary
is um there's things that i'll never
share with the world because no one
could benefit from them
um and that's okay um that's for me and
my treatment team
i love that because it's sexy it's
mysterious
it's fun it makes people want to know
more
it makes people think oh my god there's
even more to this person than they've
already been so gracious to let me in
about
that being said how do you feel
now that you have put that out there in
the documentary
well so i i actually feel like
it's just easier to be transparent
and honest with people because
i couldn't i don't know it just there's
nothing
less appealing to me than pretending
something didn't happen when it did
and then living a lie trying to pretend
that way like that
that's not appealing to me whatsoever
and i've just never been
that kind of person anyway so i feel
like it was
sometimes in a way like my my only
option but not in a sense where i felt
obligated it was just
it was the only thing that felt good to
me
absolutely yeah